[Music]
hell I'm Jeffrey Franco I'm a tech lead
on Android studio and I'm they're
responsible for programming languages
and compilers and I'm Hadi developer
advocate at Jeb brains okay so it's been
two years since Google announced
Copeland support for Android and
yesterday we announced that it was going
: first so we figured we give you some
background on this and so of course we
didn't start two years ago we took quite
some time to get things ready for
Copeland on Android and really started
about three three and a half years ago
it was a bunch of us language geeks at
Google Tourneur beaver monkey me
starting to play with Copeland and like
hey this is actually quite nice and of
course Android studio is based on
IntelliJ and intelligence arted using
Copeland in its own code base so we
start to see more and more code and
being used in Android studio and at the
same time we were getting a lot of
customer feedback from our customers
Rhys rewards surveys and ad-hoc
discussions at conferences like these
that people really like Kotlin and they
really would like Google to support it
because their companies would not adopt
Collin otherwise of course taking on a
new language like that is a big task so
we had to convince our directors that
this was something worth investing in
the best way we found to do this was to
just gather the vectors to code for a
couple days in Cortland and after that
they were sold so a couple months before
i/o 2017 we decided to go for it and
this meant so many meetings to set this
all up if you think as a tech leader or
manager you don't have enough time for
coding anymore try setting up a
foundation so we got this already one
day before coupling about before Google
i/o 2017 there was this big threat on
Android dev subreddit how Google is
never gonna embrace Scotland of course
we knew what was gonna happen with it
was so hard to not reply to that threat
so yeah two years ago Steph was on stage
announcing coupling support I think it
was the largest applause of the
developer keynote it was amazing of
course we all knew at both jetbrains and
Google that that meant that we had a lot
of work ahead of us to make sure that
Koplin worked well for Android and in
general and so today we want to show
some of the work we've done over the
last two years
Hoddy will talk about what happened to
Copeland in the last few years and then
I'll take it back and I'll talk about
what we did on the Android side
thank you so to start I want to just
mention about the Kotlin Foundation
which if you remember when Google
announced official supports two years
ago for Cortland we also briefly
mentioned that will be forming a
foundation which was created by gerunds
in Google to protect promote and advance
the language Carl in the foundation is
governed by Board of Directors which are
two representative Gibran's two of
Google and one independent member and to
give you a little bit of idea on what
the scope of the foundation is there's
one of the jobs is to appoint a language
lead designer which currently of courses
are Andre breslov and there's a language
committee that controls breaking changes
and and it's very important here to
understand that this is limited in terms
of scope so it is only about breaking
changes calling continues to be
developed as it is now in the open on
github we still have the keep which is a
Kotlin evolution enhancement process but
the language committee is mostly around
controlling the breaking changes that
might happen into the language and also
there's a trademark subcommittee that is
about protecting the trademark of
Colleen and working with the community
to help promote Kotlin and use Kotlin in
a fair way if you want to find out more
about the foundation you can go to the
cart landline website where you'll have
more information as well as details
about how you can use Kotlin and
trademarks etc and with that let's
switch over to the demo and I'm going to
show you some things with the language
[Applause]
this is where I'm using someone else's
machine see how this goes
I think the IDS correct yes
okay so I'll show you some things around
the language so probably the most
fundamental most important thing that we
have done which has taken a very very
long time if you're familiar with
writing a call an application you have
your main entry point so we've actually
now made that so you don't have
parameters okay so that's it thank you
Jeffrey want um we took two years now so
we'll start with some small things we've
done with the language itself so for
instance you know one of the things with
the when statements is that often you
have to capture the value of a variable
and then you have to examine that
variable and you only using that inside
your actual when statement so we've made
this a little bit nicer in that you can
essentially declare the variable inside
the when statement itself so you don't
have to have it reference outside of the
scope and this gives you the the
semantic Ness in your language so that
people understand that this is actually
limited to just the conditional but
let's talk about a little bit more some
nice features that we've introduced not
that those weren't nice I'm just saying
nicer features that we've introduced so
let's say that I have for instance an
application and I want to create a class
okay and I'm gonna create my class and
it's gonna quote we call the
microservice API now I can create an
instance of my microservice API and I'll
say microservice API there we go now the
thing is I don't know if this
microservice thing is gonna last it
might just be a fad so what I want to do
is tell people that are using this that
this is kind of like an experimental
feature so what we can do is we can
actually create an annotation class and
I can say for example this is a new API
and then annotate that annotation class
with this other class called
experimental and now I can use that new
experimental annotation
that I have created on anything that I
consider experimental in my API so I
could add this new API here and as soon
as I do that notice that this is going
red so it's giving me a compiler error
right it's saying that you cannot use
this because this is an experimental
feature if we hover over is saying that
it's experimental and in fact we can
change that we can say that instead of
being it being an error we can actually
define it as the warning right so here
it could be a warning and it's just now
going to show up as a warning so in
order to use this the developer has to
essentially opt in to this feature so
what I could do is hit alt enter and now
that adds the new API to my function
calls so anywhere where I'm using this
it is saying that this is an
experimental feature this gives people
idea into you can now create api's that
could be experimental and you know kind
of like I'm not gonna guarantee anything
if tomorrow we want to change something
it's okay you had the warning you did
hit alt enter I saw you hit alt enter
it's okay it's your own fault
and one of the things that we've
actually done with this is we've
introduced this concept of contract so
if you're familiar with a little bit our
code contracts we've introduced this as
an experimental feature in Kotlin as
well so let's say that I have some
function and that is like for example
print length and this is going to take a
string that is not able and then it's
going to do if string is not null I'm
going to do print line length now this
works and it's done a smart cast to a
string a non audible string because it
detects that I've already found out that
this is not inaudible so I can do this
smart house but if I were to take this
and instead of doing not null I do
something like not now and I go ahead
and create my function so let's say I
create my function that is a string and
not now that's going to return a boolean
and then I say return this is not null
you see that it doesn't have that effect
because the compiler doesn't guarantee
that that is actually not not able so it
would really nice to kind of tell the
compiler that this function complies
with a certain contract and you could do
this in column by defining using the
contract lambda the contract function
which is contract and I can say that
that's imported and I can say return
true implies that this not null is not
no okay now this gives an error ignore
it no I'm joking
the reason that this gives an error is
because this as I mentioned is an
experimental feature and there's two
ways I showed you the first one you
could add the annotation but if you add
the annotation that doesn't propagate so
if something is using that API that also
has to add the annotation you can add
the propagating annotation to this which
is this format and now I don't have to
do that and as soon as I add that notice
that this now automatically against
costs to string that is not not able
okay so this allows you to actually
create contracts and say that your
function matches your the arguments to a
function match certain conditions and
that basically is guaranteeing you a
certain level of code correctness in
your actual code so what else have we
been working on well we've done this
thing called serialization which is a
serialization library which is
multi-platform and in that is targeting
JVM JavaScript called the native iOS Mac
OS Linux Windows Embedded I think I
mentioned everything under the Sun and
this is a multi-platform library that
doesn't require any kind of reflection
and it's part of some of the offerings
that we're doing as part of like the
language and the ecosystem around it so
here you can see that I have a class a
typical data class and I have added this
serializable annotation to it which is
part of the callin serialization library
and then I have a bunch of I have a
customer and I have a customer a list of
customers so I could do something like
print line and then here I'm going to do
json stringify
customers and indicate the serializer i
want to use and then pass in the actual
customer and i could do exactly the same
thing for a list of customers so I could
do lists here and then pass in the list
of customers and if I were to run this
well this is basically going to do is
output that data class in JSON and we
have support for JSON we have support
for protobuf and other things are coming
are in the works and we can obviously do
the reverse as well so I could say for
example let's say that I have some JSON
here so let's go ahead and create some
JSON and edit so we'll do ID equals 1
and then name eCos me and then email
equals you at me calm I'm so creative
and now I can do print line and in this
case I'm going to do json.parse passing
again the serializer and then the actual
JSON that I want to pass in and what
this will do is essentially create the
actual data class object for me in
rivers and you can see that it also has
support for it creates the data object
for me in Reverse what did I do email
name email field source is required no
it's not
No that should actually write anyway so
that was working
that's Jeffrey he did something I really
like when people clap so I don't know
what's happening there but that's the
good thing about live demos I wanna I
want to make sure that something goes
wrong I actually did that on purpose so
I've done that as an exercise so that
later you come to me in office hours and
you tell me what's wrong with that okay
let's move on the next thing I want to
show you is a quick overview also on
terms of annotation classes here we've
added some additional things for support
for enums for example I can get the have
enums in my annotation I can have nested
annotations I can have properties as
part of my companion object so again
this gives me more expressiveness in
when I'm using the actual annotations
now there's one other thing that we've
been working on which you may have heard
about which is Multi multi platform
programming and the idea behind multi
platform programming which is a mouthful
is the idea that right now Colin allows
you to target different types of
platforms so I can target the JVM I can
target JavaScript I can target native
etc now one of the great things about
this is the ability to be able to share
code because there's a lot of code that
I want to end up sharing right there's
business logic there's validation logic
etc that I want to end up sharing so how
do we kind of do this this is where
we've introduced the concept of
multi-platform programming and as a
consequence of that you now have the
idea of having this multi-platform
project so you can see here that I've
got this project in my IDE and I'm
targeting different kinds of platforms
so I have Mac OS I have JVM and I have
JavaScript and then I have a series of
common code which is called common and
inside here I have some code so here I
have this function called hello that is
saying hello from platform dot name and
platform Dom name is a property of
objects
but the difference is that this object
has this word in front of it which is
called expect so what this is saying is
that this is some code that I can
reference in my common code but the
implementation is not actually provided
here the implementation is going to
provided on different types of platforms
in a different way because it can vary
based on the platform so you can see
that it's got this cute little a in the
corner here and if we hit alt enter when
we say go to declaration it asks me
which platform declaration do I want to
go to so if I say JVM it will take me to
the JVM 1 if I go back and I say go to
actual declaration on Mac OS it will
take me to the Mac OS 1 right so for
different platforms I can have different
implementations and yet I can reference
that code in my common code and use it
as part of my shared codebase and a cool
thing so kind of like think about as a
little bit like interfaces and then the
implementation of those interfaces and
the cool thing is that you get the
static compile time checking so to speak
so if I were to comment this out and I
go back here you can see that it's
giving me an error saying that one of
the actual platforms is missing an
implementation so this is allowing you
to now create multi-platform projects
that allow you to share common code base
and then have specific implementations
based on the actual target a little bit
differently okay
and that's part of the multi platform
project that we are offering moving
forward with Colin allowing you to for
example create Android applications that
share common code base with Android iOS
etc and if we can switch back to slides
I will talk to you a little bit about
some of the other things that we've been
bringing to call in the language we have
more standard library api's we're still
keeping the API numbers of method calls
kind of low but we're adding a lot more
functionality in that area
support for unsigned integers anybody
know yes
I just added that because I know someone
always claps about that obviously we
announce packet : Kampf in 2018 that
Carlin native has hit beta in terms of
tooling we've provided improved
performance speed parallel builds for
greater projects incremental annotation
processing with capped and a shout-out
to avant-garde relic from Google for
helping us with that new type inference
engine which helps in a lot of cases in
interoperability especially if you're
doing things around rx as well as making
the language a little bit more concise
when you're using builders etc and we've
introduced this progressive mode which
is essentially allowing you to try out
call and try out new features even if
those features will actually break some
code so that's a flag that you can now
enable with call in to kind of live a
little bit more on the edge and with
that I'll hand it off to Geoffrey that's
going to show you some other things that
we've been doing in Android specifically
thanks Ari I think there is one feature
that you forgot to demo I I have no idea
what you're talking about okay I'll show
it in my demo you probably broke it okay
so let's take a look at what we have
done in the Android side to support : so
let's first start with the OS of course
the OS works on bytecode so there's not
a lot we need to do to support Coplin
but we did make sure that we added
correctness and performance tests so
that we don't break Copland patterns we
implemented a couple specific
performance optimizations based on those
tests specifically for loop or
optimizations and then the big thing we
did on the OS site is improve debugging
support Copelan has a couple of
constructs like inline functions that
you don't have in other languages and so
the new version of Android now support
debugging that better then next step the
Android frameworks
there's a lot of things that happen
there the big thing is that we added API
annotations so that's not complete yet
but any new API we now have no mass and
default parameter default value
annotations so you can use those from
Coppin and we're working through the
existing API to annotate it as well then
we added this cotton extension api's so
these are ex
libraries that you include in your
project that provide extra api's through
extension methods that make your cotton
code more automatic then we added
co-routine support for a whole bunch of
the jetpack libraries so this allows you
to write asynchronous code in a more
procedural way and of course yesterday
we announced jetpack compose which is
all Kotlin so let's take a look at the
demo okay so I've built a small app here
it downloads a list of shows that are
available from a server using retrofit
and then it checks against the local
sequel database if I have watch these
shows using the room api's so here you
see that I have defined the API to get a
list of shows in both using rx Java as
well as using the Kotlin poverty the
async feature and you see that the api's
are pretty much the same with like just
a little different return type and the
room side sorry
where I could go
okay we'll skip the okay it's pretty
much hear this story so you see the same
thing have I watched the show Rx and
Java it's very similar here's the
flowable there says to spend so the API
is pretty similar now let's look at the
K if you call that code between Rx and
Java Rx and co-routines so in our X we
use a lot of operators to view our show
at the RF flow with all the asynchronous
calls and this can become pretty complex
and you see that this code is
highlighted yellow it means that there's
something I know I'm doing with the
return type so you need to make sure
that when you subscribe he deal with the
the subscription of course Rx brought
great express ability to Java and the
inventors of rx they were they were
smart they'd been what they're building
but they were limited by the language
and Kotlin we now have co-routines
and we can actually do this much nicer
so here of the same code using
co-routines
we first get the list of shows from the
server and then we call this a weight
function and the ID tells you hey
there's something asynchronous going on
here then we can use regular for loops
it's right over return shows and then we
make our asynchronous call to see if I
ever watch this show in the local
database and then we continue from there
and then here you see this large call
which will tell you hey make this call
to make sure that we notified that the
data set is changed on the UI thread and
so nice thing here is that it looks more
procedural and when I do my debugging so
launch now
there we go
and that's not working of course every
right so doing so you see that I can
actually look at variables from the
whole method not just from the specific
operator and so it makes your life much
easier when you're debugging your
asynchronous code so let's switch back
to the slides
okay so next Android tooling we've done
a lot of stuff in Android studio to make
sure that coupling is supported well the
first thing I did is we made sure that
the cotton plugin is part of Android
studio so that we can test it well
before release it and we also work
closely with JetBrains anytime they
applied update the cotton plugin we test
it before they go public to make sure
that Android studio and Coplin work well
together
next we added Android specific
refactoring support there's a lot of
actions in the IDE that are Android
specific refactorings and we're working
on adding support for those all of those
in cotton on the lint side Lind has
pretty much completely rewritten
its used to write second Alice which
checks for Java language now it uses
this thing called you ast which allows
you to write the same Lin check once and
then it can analyze both Kotlin and Java
code
we added project templates so that when
you creating a new fragment or a new
activity you have Kotlin code Bryden
starts you don't have to convert that
then on the compiler side our new
shrinker array has a lot of colon
specific optimization it's so that you
get the benefit of making your code as
small as possible
and of course the IDE has now support
for the jetpack compose a framework own
documentation and sample sites if you
look at developers anyway they've come
all api references now have both cotton
and Java syntax available there is a
content specific documentation portal
which will tell you how to get started
on Cortland how to use call routines etc
you also see that a lot of the samples
and snippets now have Copeland available
that's both on the sides on our github
samples as well as if you look on Google
i/o this year you'll see that most of
the presentations from Android clear
samples in Copeland
there's a couple of apps that you can
take a look at as well the Google i/o
app as well as this new Android
sunflower app have been build up from
the ground up using Copelan we often get
asked hey it's great if you guys are
recommending Kotlin but are you using it
yourself and of course that's a very
fair question and now at Google we have
a lot of in-house developer tools and so
it took us some time to add Copland
support to those we started out with
internal apps for Googlers
for instance there is an internal app
that shows you maps and office locations
and so we learned a lot from that and
then since then we have actually started
using Kotlin in some of the public
Google apps and so here are some of the
apps are shipping content code on your
phones today and you can expect many
more to follow talking about adopting
Cortland if you look at the whole
ecosystem we've seen that in active
development an active element is
absolute have had an upload to the Play
Store in the last six months we see that
16% of the apps are now using Kotlin and
keep in mind an app can be updated it
just because there's one bug fix or one
asset chains so 16% is pretty impressive
that's five times growth since last i/o
and if you look at the top thousand apps
that's actually already a lot bigger 44%
of the apps there we see using cotton so
that brings us to Kotlin first you now
said yesterday and so I wanted to give
you a bit more of a few of why we did it
and what it's going to mean so why would
we announce Scotland first we see strong
adoption of people using Kotlin and we
see a big excitement in the community
when people start using cotton in fact
when people are asked in our surveys on
how much happier using call in they
actually scored 25% higher than people
are not using Coplin many occur apps
across the industry and inside Google
are now using Kotlin we've reached out
to many of our customers including our
customers Rhys reward any like keep
focused on an investment in Courtland
so what does that mean of course we're
going to keep supporting the Java
programming language in many aspects
right platform Android studio support
leans back talks and relax that's not
going away but if you look at some other
efforts like our online training samples
will first do Kotlin and then Java
foreign language will be best effort and
then of course there are some features
like the multi-platform projects and
jetpack compose that are only going to
be offered in content
now of course the next question that we
hear from people is well does it mean I
should switch please don't take Copeland
first as I need to go take all my Java
code and rewrite it and call them that's
not what we want you to do like look at
the Android studio that is many many
hundred thousand lines of code right now
we're about 10 percent Cullen of the
Android studio specific code and so what
we do is we only take new functionality
right at hand : and it is possible
because Coughlin has great
interoperability with Java you can write
a single class in Copeland and keep the
rest in Java or keep have 99% of your
coding cotton and have only some
leftovers in Java of course it matters
what is your current state of your
project and team if you want a week away
from shipping your release app orient
the rest and best time to switch the
clock line but if you're starting a new
development cycle and you're like hey I
could for you take on call them and of
course it depends on your team as well
are they interested in Cortland are they
do they feel secure taking this on we
have also found that a lot of people
actually use mentioning cotton in their
recruitment that they can get a lot more
candidates so things to consider of
course on the technical side is also
trade-offs to consider Kotlin brings
great features lower productivity and
satisfaction but you have to think about
learning curve it takes time for people
to learn to write idea Matic kopplin we
see that most people who start writing
Coplin the first week they're really
writing Java in cotton and it takes them
three to six months to to really start
writing item at a coupling that's fine I
mean you still get all the benefits of
Copelan warning you about known as etc
then there's the build speed Koplin is
slower than the Java compiler it's doing
more work for you and it's a younger
compiler we are working hard on making
it faster and of course keep in mind yes
it's slower but you have to do fewer
builds because your app will most likely
be correct there and there's also apk
size the app uses standard library and
it takes some space but things like our
rate can help you reduce that there's a
whole bunch of ongoing cut line we're
going on at Google of course jetpack
compose is the biggest thing there we
always keep adding new KTX api's all the
time and then on the compiler side we
doing a lot of work to make it faster
and like with : 3 103 30 we added in
communication and it eight processors
and there's much more to come you'll see
more improved tooling and more Docs and
samples using content if you're
interested in using Cortland but you're
not sure where to start we are
announcing Kotlin everywhere which is a
set of trainings hosted by both Google
and JetBrains and it's happening between
now and Cortland profit December at the
end of the year if you're interested in
that either participating or helping
hosting it go to this link and sign up
so with our new Copeland first web map
the investments in Copeland for Android
is only going to become larger I'd like
to invite all of you who haven't tried
popped in yet or haven't recently used
it to try it in your app today I hope
you'll have a similar experience like me
with Cortland you'll be more predictive
and have more fun coding thank you very
much
[Music]